Beh moi je m'appelle Yoras.
Je viens de la capitale.
Et on m'a envoyé ici parce qu'il y a un fils de dragon.
Techniquement, je suis obligé de l'anoblir.
Je suis obligé de faire une cérémonie, pour bien officialiser le truc.
Là, ils sont à fond là.
Y sont à fond.
Ils adorent ça les bouseux les cérémonies.
Oui.
Aelys De Lyor.
Présent !
Non mais...
Je sais qui vous êtes, c'est pas l'appel...
C'est une cérémonie donc je suis obligé de faire ça pour...
- Ah pardon, j'ai paniqué.
Ne parlez pas, je vais essayé de...
- Oui je sais, j'aurais pas dû.
Mais je suis stressé !
J'ai pas l'habitude...
Taisez-vous là !
Ok.
Aelys De Lyor, vous avez survécu au bûcher.
Prouvant par la même que vous êtes un vrai fils du dragon.
La capitale vous octroi donc le titre de seigneur...
Aelys du dragon.
Mais aussi...
Un garde royal.
Une armure du dragon.
En héritage de vos aïeuls.
Et par décision du roi...
Vous co-gèrerez...
Le petit Royaume des Forgz.
Quoi ?
Co-quoi ?
Vous co-gérerez.
C'est gérer à deux, en fait.
Mais au futur.
C'est très flatteur pour Aelys hein...
Mais... il refuse.
J'accepte !
Non mais... attendez... si je refuse ?
Vous désobéissez au roi ?
Oui, alors... j'ai dit "si".
La priorité de la capitale est l'entente avec sir Aelys.
Seigneur Belyr, à partir d'aujourd'hui...
Vous partagez votre pouvoir avec sir Aelys du dragon.
C'est compris ?
Est-ce que c'est compris ?!
Oui !
C'est hyper gênant là...
Est-ce qu'on peut s'en aller ?
Ma famille est de sang noble.
Elle a construit ce château pierre par pierre.
Mes ancêtres, au prix de nombreux sacrifices...
Ont obtenu le statut de seigneur.
Bien, c'est la première réunion du conseil depuis la décision injuste du roi.
Donc, quel est l'injuste ordre du jour ?
L'insécurité croissante dans notre région.
C'est vrai ça.
Ça craint ici, y a même des vols de Royaume et tout, hein.
Bon...
Contre la violence...
Je propose la culture.
J'aimerais organiser des pièces de théâtre.
C'est des petites histoires qu'on raconte aux gens...
Avec une morale à la fin.
Comme, tuer c'est mal.
Voler c'est mal.
Trahir son seigneur c'est mal.
Ça nous permettrait de les éduquer et de leur apprendre à penser par eux-mêmes
Apprendre aux gens à penser par eux-mêmes ? Non, non, non...
Les pauvres c'est bien pour nous tant qu'ils savent pas qu'ils sont pauvres.
C'est tout l'intérêt du truc.
Mais la culture c'est primordiale !
Les histoires ça leur permettraient de supporter leur quotidien.
On a le plus gros taux de mortalité du pays.
Les gens meurent de la peste et du choléra.
Les gens, ils veulent pas des histoires, ils veulent de la pommade.
Mais les histoires...
C'est un peu la pommade pour l'esprit.
Je suis parti en impro.
Non !
Proposition suivante.
Alors, de mon côté...
Je propose de créer des soirées dansantes dans les villages.
Cela permettrait, aux hommes et aux femmes...
De se rencontrer de façon plus civilisé.
Les rencontres elles sont pas déjà civilisés là ?
La plupart des unions sont forcées.
Et alors ?
Qu'est-ce que...
Elle se lève elle maintenant.
Les hommes et les femmes arriveraient bien habillés.
On apprendrait des petits pas de danse.
Et ça dure combien de temps ?
Ok, c'est super long.
Et saluer...
Bon, et à quel moment on déflore la pucelle ?
On déflore rien du tout !
Et le droit de cuissage ?
Hein ?
Les seigneurs ils ont le droit de faire ça, c'est un privilège ancestral ça.
On peut changer la loi.
Non.
Et toi qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Moi je m'en fous un peu.
Non je veux dire, ne trouves-tu pas qu'aider les femmes à choisir leur époux...
C'est un changement aussi positif que t'as co-gestion du Royaume.
Que ma co-gestion du Royaume ?
Très positive.
Ok.
Oui, oui.
Oui, j'aime beaucoup ça le...
La danse.
Et le théâtre !
Quoi ?
Ah oui !
Parce que tout ce qu'il a dit, c'était super.
Bah merci, merci seigneur Aelys.
Voilà ! Donc ça fait Yorel...
Seigneur Aelys, et moi...
Pour la danse et le théâtre.
Trois votes pour la culture !
C'est ça !
Comme je le présentais, cette co-gestion...
Ça va pas être possible.
Clarisse.
Belyr.
On est d'accord que, cette histoire de co-gestion avec Aelys...
C'est n'importe quoi.
Alors, je me demandais, est-ce que tu pourrais pas faire ce que font les femmes ?
C'est-à-dire ?
Bah ce que font les femmes quoi.
Tu le séduis avec un filtre d'amour.
Après tu couches avec lui, de façon totalement débridée.
Et puis dans son sommeil...
Tu le tues !
Et t'aspires son âme, le regard tourné vers les flammes de la cheminé.
Je peux pas faire ça.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je suis pas une sorcière.
Bien sûr que non.
Personne n'est une sorcière.
Je ne tue pas les gens.
Ok !
Ok.
Pas de soucis.
Admettons.
Ok.
C'est gentil de me donner un coup de main.
Je crois même que c'est la première fois.
Faut un début à tout.
En revanche, cette histoire de co-habitation...
Ça me fait un petit peu peur pour Aelys.
Décision du roi, on peut rien faire.
Pour le moment.
Mais...
On vend beaucoup de poison.
Un accident c'est vite arrivé.
Non.
Non, non, c'est très rare les accidents dans le Royaume.
Mais imaginons...
Qu'une fiole s'égare là, comme ça...
C'est possible ça ?
Non, parce que moi je fais très attention...
Imaginons !
Ok.
Y a une fiole qui s'égare...
On sait pas où elle est...
C'est quand même possible ça ?
Non...
Mais tu vas t'énerver.
T'es négatif Yorel !
T'es hyper négatif !
C'est pour ça, voilà, range les tes bouquins !
Oh puis tu veux ranger encore ?
Range, voilà, range !
Arrête !
Faut tout faire soi-même !
Tout !
Bon bah c'est bien.
Hein ?
Encore une bonne réunion qui se termine.
On peut y aller.
Bonne soirée.
Les mystères sont de mise !
Aaaaaah !